in 2011 dutch scientists connected mice
to a brain scanner and
cut their heads off they discovered that
mice remained conscious for up to four
seconds after decapitation other studies
show that small mammals remained aware
for up to 29 seconds now if this is also
true for humans it would provide enough
time for a pretty gruesome experience
and might also explain some pretty
grisly stories from history so does a
human head remain conscious after being
separated from its body it sure does
let's find out why
[Music]
a common method of execution throughout
history has been beheading and it's easy
to see why it sends a powerful message
that kept citizens in line for thousands
of years throughout history we find many
stories about how some decapitated heads
still move their eyes or make facial
expressions usually of anguish or
despair some have even made sounds
despite being severed from the rest of
their body there's even a famous story
about a man who attended the execution
of his friend during the french
revolution the seconds after the
guillotine fell the man retrieved the
severed head and asked it a series of
questions and through blinking and
facial expressions the victim allegedly
communicated with his friend this type
of post head chopped off consciousness
is called lucid decapitation so
scientists and doctors started to ask
the question does a person really stay
conscious and aware after losing their
head well the answer is not only is it
possible but it's medically proven
debate on the subject started ever since
charlotte corday was guillotined in 1793
for murder the executioner's assistant
lifted her head by the hair and slapped
it on both cheeks for some reason and
eyewitnesses reported that quote her
face took on an angry expression and for
a moment or two there was a look of a
ghastly stare which implied that the
head was aware of its ignominious
situation the
it means humiliating i know what it
means
anyway
french doctors argue that witnesses were
confusing nervous spasms with voluntary
motion and very little research was
conducted on the subject until 1905 when
a french doctor named barrow was allowed
to make an investigation of a severed
head his um
subject was a criminal named henri
lungieel and immediately after
guillotining here's what dr barreaux
wrote in his journal after the
decapitation the eyelids and lips
spasmed for about five seconds the face
relaxed the leads half closed leaving
only the whites visible it was then that
they called out in a strong voice
longhill as in so the eyelids slowly
lift up this even movement quite
distinct and normal such as with people
awakened or torn from their thoughts
next longeel's eyes definitely fixed on
mine and the pupils focused i was not
then dealing with a vague dull look i
was dealing with undeniably living eyes
which were looking at me after several
seconds the eyelids closed again i
called out again and once more without
any spasm the eyelids lifted and living
eyes fixed themselves on mine with more
penetration since the first time since
there was a further closing of the
eyelids but now less complete i
attempted this third call but there was
no further movement
and the eyes took on the glazed look
which they have in the dead
[Music]
um
are you okay dear sport
hello
oh boy not again
sorry folks the human gets a little
squeamish
uh oh we'll be back after these messages
by the mid 20th century the government
of france wasn't so sure beheading was
as painless as its supporters claimed in
the 1950s a study by doctors pio de
livre and fournier concluded that death
by guillotine is not instantaneous the
report said every vital element survives
decapitation the last man to be
guillotined in france was tunisian-born
killer hamida danjubi in 1977. don jubi
became the last person in western europe
to be executed by the state before
france officially abolished capital
punishment in 1981. the french
authorities had already banned public
executions after the heading of eugene
wiedman in 1939 this event was secretly
filmed by a member of the crowd in
versailles and once the horrible film
made the rounds the government preferred
to do its killing in private however
there is one decapitated head which
still sort of lives on at the university
of lisbon's facility of medicine diogo
alves was portugal's first serial killer
and one of the last people to be
executed in the country in 1841. his
severed head was actually cut off and
studied by scientists following his
hanging and is now preserved in a glass
jar in the medical school they had this
head for 150 years yup
why keep it sometimes it's just really
hard to throw things away
[Music]
okay so chopping off your head doesn't
result in immediate death but just how
long do you actually survive some
doctors have said a human head could
survive up to 15 minutes but it's
probably just a few seconds when the
brain runs out of oxygen this is called
anoxia and all motor functions stop
though the headless body lives on for
about another minute until the heart
stops pumping but if we look at some
other animals some of them can survive
for longer than you think
cockroaches can live for weeks without
their head and if the wound is able to
seal itself off well it just keeps on
going
headlessly a decapitated snake's head
can still bite you and release venom
without its body headless frogs still
jump snapping turtles still snap for
hours
just the heads but the craziest headless
animal has got to be the chicken
specifically miracle mike no the movie
with the male strippers no no no that's
magic mike yeah i don't think you're
right about that
i am
miracle mike was a chicken who belonged
to a farmer in colorado named lloyd
olson and lloyd was planning on having a
little chicken dinner but after chopping
off miracle mike's head he kept walking
around the farmer kept walking around no
miracle mike the chicken what yup he was
able to balance himself run around and
was still trying to peck for food
so lloyd decided to keep him as a pet oh
no this
this isn't real oh it is
lloyd fed miracle mike a mixture of milk
and water with an eye dropper to keep
him alive and even dropped small grains
of corn down mike's
neck hole gross just get a puppy for
crying out loud this is crazy what's
even crazier is miracle mike lived for
18 more months without his head he went
on tour made public appearances he was
even on the cover of time life magazine
that's a terrible way to become famous
miracle mike was considered to be very
healthy the only reason he died was
because one of those corn kernels got
stuck in his nickel
right it is a lesson in there somewhere
probably
but i don't know what it is
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learn anything do me a favor and like
subscribe comment and share all that
stuff really helps out the channel and
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you are appreciated
[Music]
[Applause]
you